what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
story lines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this
channel so I think it kind of goes
without saying at this point that Old
Man Logan
is it's my favorite story my favorite
comic coming out of all new all
different Marvel right now I mean Jeff
lamir and Santino man this is the these
guys are like the onew punch of Marvel
Comics right now I mean they're knocking
it out of the park with Old Man Logan
because of some of the best storytelling
involving Wolverine in fact I can't
think of any storytelling involving
Wolverine that's ever been this good
like ever in the history of Marvel
Comics this ever been this good the
closest I can think of is the miniseries
Weapon X which dealt with the original
Wolverine's time as part of the Weapon X
Project it literally detailed it all
like every instance every Circumstance
the whole nine yards from the time that
he was kidnapped as part of Team X and
forced into the Weapon X Program up
until the time that he escaped it was
actually a really really cool story it
was something like 12 or 13 maybe 15
issues I can't remember off the top of
my head I should do that at some point
in time like I should I should do that
story but in any event we pick up here
in madore because remember right now
this story comes after Bordertown
meaning that this is the circumstance
whereby Lady Death Strike had gone
through tried to capture Old Man Logan
believing he was wolverin or at the very
least you know some aged version of
wolver rain and intended to take him
prisoner or at least kill him but in
doing so had tracked him to a place
called Bordertown and had killed several
innocent families which led to you know
her escaping after Wolverine attack her
and then him tracking her down for the
purpose of killing her in Revenge for
her killing a family and so because of
this uh magor I guess in Tokyo rather
this deals with the concept of madore
and the idea that lady Death Strike may
be holding up there now in Marvel Comics
madore is kind of the Wild West like
Mador is if any of you guys ever saw
John Wick John Wick the movie with Keo
Reeves where you had like that hotel
that all the bounty hunters stayed at
that is what Mador is like it's where
almost some of the best criminals in the
world some of the most powerful
criminals in the world hang out at so in
madore you'll find Lady Death Strike
you'll find Mystique uh you might find
Magneto every once in a while uh Shield
knows enough to stay hands off from
madore it's one of the places that they
just won't go to because literally
there's no rules like if you show up in
madore and you start a fight people will
kill you and no one will ask questions
no one will arrest you no one will take
you to jail like it's it's literally
just the wild west of the Marvel
Universe but because of the fact that
she may be holding up there initially uh
Old Man Logan goes to a guy named e now
what he does is he uses a name called
patches and that was a name that he
actually used back in the day um when he
was wanting to keep his identity
Anonymous the problem with this is that
the reemergence of Old Man Logan after
the death of the original Wolverine has
turned a lot of people on to the fact
that he may still be alive because of
the fact that you know the original
Wolverine had incurred so many enemies
these enemies have now become the
enemies of Old Man Logan so he's
literally dealing with the aftermath of
the original Wolverine's life and so
when he makes contact with ETO he says
look I want to know where Lady Death
Strike is and the agreed sum was 1
million yen Old Man Logan would bring
him a million yen and ETO would reveal
the Identity or I guess the location of
Lady Death Strike the problem with this
is that there's bounties on the head of
Old Man Logan and one of these bounties
amasses to a sum of 3 million yen
meaning that itto has basically ratted
out Old Man Logan and in doing so uh it
resulted in you know the Yakuza
effectively coming after him now of
course you know this is not designed to
be the main brunt of the story this is
really just uh you know Jeff lamir
showing us where Old Man Logan is at
this point in time and the kind of that
he does and of course as with the
original Wolverine he's the best at what
he does and what he does is killing It's
Kind of a Funny situation you know
seeing him lash out and such a way
because it adds a different Dynamic to
the Wolverine mythology in the sense
that you know the old the old Wolverine
had an almost instantaneous healing
Factor up until he lost it old man
Logan's healing factor is much slower
just due to his age just due to the fact
that he's gotten older his body is
literally just slowing down in much the
same way that as we get older our organs
begin to slow down and eventually fail
leading to our deaths for Old Man Logan
his healing Factor begins to slow slow
down and he will eventually die of old
age just because his healing Factor will
essentially just stop it'll just stop
working and he'll be like a normal human
being at that point his organs will
begin to age normally so he'll have an
extra hundred years or so on his life
but you know in terms of his physical
appearance in terms of how he'll look
he'll stay relatively similar which is
why he's aged 20 years or so over the
course of you know 3 or 400 years but
the idea here is we also get some
flashbacks and this is what Jeff lir
does he jumps back and forth between the
past and the present in the sense that
we initially pick up in the weapon x
bunker in the wastelands during the
original Old Man Logan Universe now of
course we knew that Wolverine I guess
that Old Man Logan was in love with Meen
she was the woman he was married to and
had children with during the Mark Miller
Old Man Logan story but what Jeff lamir
has been doing for those of you guys who
were just now jumping on to Comic
explaining the Old Man Logan stories
what Jeff lamir has been doing up to
this point is effectively going through
and filling in the gaps between what
happened from the start of Old Man Logan
off panel to the actual beginning of the
story he's going through and just kind
of filling in these holes the journey
that Logan took after he you know killed
the X-Men and then then eventually uh
you know where the Old Man Logan story
started off and so the issue with this
is that North America has become a very
very violent place we knew that from The
Old Man Logan Story by Mark Miller the
original you know limited run we knew
that North America had become a
dangerous place you had Red Skull that
brought all the super villains together
killed all the superheroes we know that
uh the incredible Hook runs everything
basically you know west of the Rocky
Mountains we have the Kingpin or I guess
yeah I guess it used to be Magneto but
the Kingpin who runs everything in
Heartland America I mean it's a very
very you know dangerous place to be and
so because of this Marine initially
wants to leave she says well I mean we
can't stay here forever all we're going
to do is be on the run and so Logan says
okay fine then let's leave North America
let's let's leave the United States
let's go somewhere else surely there's
got to be a safe place somewhere in the
world now again we don't know how the
entirety of the world shaped up we don't
know if this is like you know Days of
Future Past or the Age of Apocalypse
where people living in Europe are safe
where you have the high human Council or
the human High Council and there's these
small little sections of the world that
are safe from the actions of super
villains or if the entire world has been
taken over including the Savage land and
Antarctica there's a lot of things that
we don't know with regards to the Old
Man Logan Universe what we do know is
that in that timeline they had basically
taken off to go to Japan the problem was
that when they got there things didn't
necessarily go their way now again this
kind of switches back to this current
moment right now in the sense that uh we
have Old Man Logan tracking down IO or I
guess you know Lady Death Strike
ultimately coming across the track in
Japan where he finds her being held
prisoner and so again jumping back and
this again is what what Jeff lir does he
just jumps back and forth between the
past and the present when Moren and Old
Man Logan get to Japan they run into a
group called The Silent order now within
the Marvel Universe the silent order was
small time I mean in truth this seems to
be their initial introduction but what
Jeff lamir says is they were a small
time organization it was like the
Sinister Six you know I mean yeah they
were composed of people who were you
know pretty powerful but in the grand
scheme of things they were a blip on the
radar and that's what the silent order
were they were a blip on the radar of
you know Japan's criminal underworld no
one ever took them seriously and they
were wildly irrelevant but but you know
during the fall of superheroes once you
know the super villains took over the
world they took over Japan and they
bolstered their ranks and effectively
killed anybody that came in there who
wasn't supposed to be there so again
jumping back to the present day when
Wolverine I guess Old Man Logan gets
into the shack and he starts speaking
with uh Lady Death Strike she says this
is a trap you know you should not have
come here they were waiting for you and
we see him you know shot with a whole
bunch of arrows and he's ultimately met
by the arrival of General so now this is
essentially Wolverine trying to keep his
future from happening because with his
character with Old Man Logan and all new
all different Marvel every day he works
is to try to keep that future from
happening whether it's killing someone
or whether it's you know playing more of
a diplomatic role uh you know taking
more of a a democratic approach to you
know any one particular situation it's
him always afraid of the fact that his
future will come to fruition and trying
to find a way to keep that from
happening and so you know what we do is
we pick up with him having been thrown
into a well and each time that he tries
to climb up he's basically thrown back
in now this is somewhat of a test by
General so you know to for him to prove
whether or not he's capable of basically
fighting against General so B get
himself free of his own prison now in
truth so just wants to keep him here I
mean he just wants to keep him as a
prisoner or at least that seems to be
the case he doesn't really want to do
anything with him he doesn't want to
kill him or anything like that he just
wants to hold him forever now we'll
actually find out the reason behind this
and what we learn is that you know
during the time in the wastelands in the
future I guess in the the alternate
reality Old Man Logan universe that when
Meen and Old Man Logan arrived in Japan
that they did come across the silent
order they tried to fight their way out
you know they tried to fight their way
free but this General so who was much
much older had again orchestrated their
captivity now something else to keep in
mind here is that Marine did not know
that Old Man Logan had a healing Factor
she didn't know what he was capable of
you all she knew was that he was a guy
who just managed to make his way out of
you know some super villain in closed
town and he eventually came across her
and then you know the two of them just
sort of got together and that was that
but she liked him because he was
honorable you know because he kept
promises so on and so forth he was the
definition of what a man should be and
so as the two fell in love Old Man Logan
never never revealed to her what he
truly was and this is where that happens
you know he says look I'm going to have
to do some things that I don't want you
to see I don't want I'm going to have to
do some things that I don't want you to
be a part of you know it's best if you
simply just close your eyes now jumping
back to the present day we again have
General so telling wol rain look we know
who you are we know what you will become
we know that you will kill our leader
who is effectively the silent monk we
know what you're about our goal at the
very least is to try to keep that from
happening is to try to prevent that from
taking place and so ultimately you know
once he makes his Escape or at least
once he get out he tells General so look
I'm going to kill you I'm going to kill
you to stop you from what it is that
you're going to do later on because
remember there are times where Old Man
Logan begins to lose grip of reality and
in his mind despite the fact that the
current Marvel universe is different
from the Old Man Logan Universe because
things are not happening in the same way
then there's no guarantee that the super
villains will take over the world and
his mind that possibility still exists
and so if killing General so means that
he will be able to protect Japan give
his wife some safe place to go to once
the super villains take over the world
then that's exact what he's going to do
but what so says is we're the silent
order which means that to attack one of
us is to attack all of us you don't just
attack me you fight all of us at the
same time and so again this is actually
a pretty badass uh scenario this
actually really works because Wolverine
or I guess Old Man Logan does exactly
that like he literally goes through and
attacks every single last one of them
not only that with Lady Death Strike
being held prisoner she's actually free
from her captivity by way of the
conflict just because of the fact that
she's freed from her bins no one really
goes and frees her in particular she
just kind of breaks out and because of
this both she and Old Man Logan are
fighting against the silent order while
working together now from here we jump
back to the wastelands again we jump
back to the original Universe of Old Man
Logan and we encounter this adult
version of the silent monk along with
General so and what happens here is you
know silent monk effectively reads the
mind of Wolverine or I guess of Old Man
Logan trying to figure out what he's
about and he learns that of course he
was part of the uh Grant Morrison's new
Xmen back in the day that he had a
relationship with storm this is really
just Jeff lamir saying the past of old
man l Lan and the original Old Man Logan
Universe was identical to the main
Marvel Universe Wolverine there was no
real deviation here everything that you
remember about Wolverine before his
death when he was covered in adamantium
is the exact same for Old Man Logan
those pasts didn't really change the
only thing that changed was the fact
that Mysterio tricked Wolverine into
killing all the X-Men as part of the
super villains rise to power and so
because of this the silent monk freaks
out because he says you've brought a a
Madman here you've brought a monster
here this guy has been bred for conflict
death and destruction you've literally
brought death to my doorstep why would
you do this and you know Old Man Logan
says whatever he doesn't even ask any
real questions he just begins attacking
every last one of them now again
transitioning back to the current moment
to the modern day we of course have Lady
Death Strike and Old Man Logan
continuing to fight against the silent
order but then it seems as though Lady
Death Strike is either severely injured
or even killed in the onslaught and so
of course Old Man Logan turns his
attention to uh General so himself and
so what we get is this sort of blend
between the past and the present because
these circum cumstances have unfolded
much the same way the actions of Old Man
Logan are different in terms of how he
engages the silent order in uh in the
wastelands in the original Old Man Logan
Universe versus the current allnew all
different Marvel Universe but in the end
it's still the same thing it all amounts
to the same thing in the sense that it
is Old Man Logan fighting General so the
problem with this is that in the main
Marvel Universe the silent monk is not
an adult he's a child he hasn't grown
into the adult that that Old Man Logan
has become fearful of now this is why I
say that Marvel seems to be introducing
a new Omega Level mutant here because
what the silent monk says is when I was
bestowed with my Powers my Powers
essentially activated you know I looked
into the future and I saw what was going
to happen I looked into the future and I
saw that you're going to kill me as an
adult and so this seems to be Jeff lamir
toying with the idea that the Old Man
Logan storyline will happen that you
know the super villains will attempt to
take over the world whether they're
successful or not at something that we
don't know but it seems like that will
take place and so in response to this
the idea of Logan is to actually take a
step back is to actually say hey look
like maybe I shouldn't kill him you know
but again you know we also get this
explanation of old men Logan's fight
with a silent order in the Old Man Logan
Universe by way of the present day
silent monk when he says you know when I
saw myself dying I saw you I saw you as
a monster you know slashing destroying
slaughtering all the members of the
silent order and then finally you turned
your claws on to me and you killed me
and he says I am not going to let that
happen now Old Man Logan says look like
you know that future is not written in
stone there's no guarantee that that's
going to happen you know not only that
these guys in the silent order are using
you for your power they're taking
advantage of you and so really the
silent Monk's being put in a
circumstance where he's being asked who
he should believe should he believe Old
Man Logan or should he believe General
so now at this point he's basically cast
back into the well again where of course
he you know encounters Lady Death Strike
but then he's grabbed he's brought right
back up again and so it seems like he's
constantly being tortured and he's
constantly being uh being controlled and
manipulated by the silent monk at the
very least to be you know forced to
endure pain and torment and so on and so
forth but switching back to Japan we
basically have Old Man Logan talking
with Moren and this is when she
essentially learns what it was that he's
about when she learns how violent he is
you know when she learns what it is that
he's capable of what Old Man Logan also
says though is that all these people who
were in Japan these normal citizens who
were trying to make their way in Japan
itself after the villains had taken over
the world they were all made into slaves
for a multitude of different purposes
the women were taken as slaves for the
men to use for their own purposes the
male citizens of Japan were taking you
know as slaves to work or whatever it is
that they ended up doing you know but
the idea is that he basically spared
Japan of a brutal dictator a brutal
warlord who was essentially bringing
Society to its knees but for marine she
has a hard time accepting this because
keep in mind this is all new to her I
mean this is fresh in her face she
literally has just witnessed the man
that she loves turn into a Savage animal
and just kill everybody you know this is
a side of him that she's never seen
before now to his defense at the very
least Old Man Logan says I didn't want
you to see this part of me like I did
not want you to see this is who I was
because it's not who I am on a
fundamental level it's who I used to be
that's who I was once upon a time but
you know after the death of the X-Men he
basically tried to walk away from
himself try to walk away from that now
the cool thing about this is that as far
as we're aware this is the last time we
will ever see Old Man Logan act in that
way until he killed the Incredible Hulk
in the Old Man Logan story and so you
know this was basically him setting
aside and saying okay look you'll never
see that part of me again you and I have
to find some place to go where we can
live our lives free and this is when
Marine says well it's not just you and
me anymore I'm a pregnant I'm with a
child now and this seems to be the
motivation for why it was that Old Man
Logan had set his claws aside why he
never popped his claws again from this
conflict in his own timeline up until he
killed the Incredible Hulk in his own
timeline because he did not want to be a
violent guy he wanted to be a father
that his children could aspire to he
wanted to live a peaceful life and he
had come to the realization that
everywhere he went when he popped his
claws death and destruction would always
follow and so by believing that he was a
source of his own problem he looked to
eliminate that source and to live a
peaceful and quiet life which is
actually pretty cool it actually works
out pretty well the problem with this is
that litty death strike in the present
day has also come to the realization
that the silent monk has to be stopped
and so you know grabbing an arrow and
throwing it through his leg General so
comes to his rescue but at this point
you know the silent Monk's fallen down
into the well and Wolverine actually
holds him hostage you know Old Man Logan
holds him hostage and says you're going
to let us out of here and you're going
to let us leave or I'm going to kill him
but the silent monk essentially comes to
you know when he wakes up when he
emerges his power just seems to run a
Muk now of course ladyy death strike was
going to try to kill him and it's left
ambiguous as to what happens to her if
she's annihilated if she's destroyed but
the silent monk just grows and mutates
into this massive being that takes on
you know whatever happens to be around
him it almost seems like he's merging
with the environment himself now the
reason why I say this seems to be an Oma
level mutant is because in Marvel Comics
The only beings that are capable of
being Omega Level are those who have
levels of telepathy and and telekinesis
that can allow them to control facets of
the universe or those who can manipulate
their surroundings and take on mass grow
to sizes uh by basically controlling the
physical structure of their own bodies
and the structure of matter around them
and so it seems like because of the fact
that silent monk is able to control the
structure of matter around him because
he's able to take on extra size it
essentially means that he's growing in
scale and it looks like he is Omega
Level in terms of the ability to control
his own body's composition and structure
and so finally you know Old Man Logan
says hey look if you don't believe the
words that I'm telling you if you don't
believe what it is that I'm saying to
you then read my mind you know scan my
mind use your telepathy your telekinesis
you know whatever it is you need to do
but scan my mind and see what I'm about
see what I've seen see where I've been
and see what it is that I'm trying to do
and that's what the silent monk does now
something I want to draw your attention
to as well because this caught me this
is the art of sorentino I mean this is
it's a full page you know collage of all
the moment this is every moment in the
mind of Old Man Logan every experience
he's ever had every single memory as an
image and it all just comes together in
this beautiful image of his head and I
love this I mean this is this is
beautifully done this is some of the
best comic book artwork that I've ever
seen in my life and it was kind of funny
because we were on the pool one day and
myself uh Caitlyn who runs the channel
That sea monster you guys should go
check out that sea monster she's a she
has an amazing Channel we were talking
about the art and the comic and it was
just like this Art's mind-blowing like
this is a poster you know we were
talking about how you could take comic
panel or you could take pages from
sortino's run of Old Man Logan and you
could turn them into posters this is a
perfect example you could frame this and
hang it up on a wall and I think that's
exactly what I'm going to do but you can
grab this and put it on a wall somewhere
because it's just so beautifully done um
I just want to draw you all's attention
to that because it shows you what kind
of Storytelling we're getting here and
what kind of artwork we're getting in
this but the fact remains that when the
silent monk comes to the realization of
what it is that Old Man Logan is about
General so tries to step in general so
tries to say no no no no you're
effectively Our God you're our divine
being you know you have to serve us and
in response you know the silent monk
essentially lashes out and leaves
General so in the silent order behind
now he doesn't actually kill them
instead it seems like he incapacitates
them but during their previous previous
discussions when BL Man Logan was
effectively bargaining for his life you
told the silent monk look there's a
place for you there's a place that you
can go to there's a place that I know of
for people who have powers like you that
don't quite know how to use them yet
come with me and I will take you there
come with me and I will show you where
you can stay where you can learn to use
your abilities where you can be with
children just like you and you're not
forced to live in isolation and function
as a God for a corrupt group of
criminals who want to use you for their
own ends and so ultimately that's what
happens you know the silent monk seems
to follow Old Man Logan and eventually
go back with him to the Xavier Institute
but we also learn is that in the
wastelands during their Journeys and
trying to find a home ultimately we pick
up with uh Old Man Logan and Marine when
they finally come across the house that
they settle in at the beginning of the
Old Man Logan storyline now what happens
between the discovery of this house and
the picking up of the story we don't
know because remember we have about a
decade and a half or so about 15 years
between this between when she gives
birth to her first child and the start
of Old Man Logan because remember they
had kids they already had like two or
three kids at that point in time and so
there's a lot that can happen here but
at the very least it gives us kind of
this return to familiarity with the Old
Man Logan storyline but if you guys are
new here to Comics explain make sure you
guys hit the Subscribe button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video drop a like leave a comment
down below let me know what you think
and I will catch you all later
[Music]
peace
now